اجرى وزير الداخليه سعودي زياره الرسميه
الى الجزائر رئيس عبد المجيد تبون استقبل
ايضا وزير الداخليه للامير عبد العزيز بن
سعود بن نايف بن عبد العزيز ال سعود لكن
من دون الاشاره الى جدول الاعمال هذه هي
الزياره والتي يرشح ان تكون لتحضير زياره
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بنسل
معنا من الجزائر العاصمه
الدوليه فيصل مطاوي اهلا بك
فيصل اذا هذه المباحثات التي اجراها
الرئيس عبد المجيد تبول ووزير الداخليه
السعودي الذي يجري زياره الرسميه الى
الجزائر لم يتم ربما الاشاره الى صحه وهذه
الزياره هل رشحها شيء همم عن هذه
المباحثات
نعم بالفعل الامير عبد العزيز بن سعود بن
نايف بن عبد العزيز ال سعود وزير الداخليه
سعودي يزور الجزائر للمره الثانيه في اقل
من سنه اولا لانه هناك تنسيق امني متواصل
بين الجزائر والرياض حول عده مواضيع في
محاربه الجماعات المتشدده والشيطان وان
الامير عبد العزيز بن سعود الذي لم يقم
بتسريح صحفي بعد استقباله من قبل الرئيس
عبد المجيد الدبون في قصر المراديه في
الجزائر في الجزائر العاصمه ولكن بحسب
معاني منها فان السيد عبد العزيز بن سعود
الجزائر
لزياره وليد العهد محمد بن سلمان التي فقد
تكون في الشهر المقبل يعني في شهر جانفي
يناير المقبل في الزياره كانت مرتبه قبل
القمه العربيه التي نظمت في الجزائر 20
ثانيه ولم يحضرها محمد بن سلمان الذي
اعتبر الذي اسلك صحيه ولكن رئيس سنور قال
ان سعوديه ستبقى دائما غياب محمد بن سلمان
هو طبعا اضافه الى عده امور متعلقه
بالعلاقات ثنائيه بين البلدين والتي تقوت
في السنوات السنوات الاخيره خاصه زياره
فيصل بن عبد الله بن فرحان ال سعود وزير
الخارجيه السعودي شهر مايو الماضي الذي
تحدث عن تنسيق بين البلدين وعن دعم
للرياضه كرشح الجزائر للحصول على على مقعد
غير دائم في مجلس الامن الدولي للا
نتخابات شهر رجب المقبل
2024-25 وبني مقابل الجزائر
الاخرى
من الجزائر في همم رفع من حجم الاستثمارات
السعوديه
جزيره شكرا لك